huh Missy Missy Missy yeah I'm probably
gonna title this a spoiler review of the
entirety of series 8 but I'm really
gonna focus almost entirely on the
finale I may touch on some other stuff
as it sort of occurs to me to do so but
let's dig into what I was dying to talk
about Missy mistress the master now this
was the twist that I had talked about I
had had spoiled for me because I saw
that as a bit of fan theory somebody
thinking this is the master me currently
because Missy mistress master and I read
that but well no it's not gonna be that
because that's kind of dumb and honestly
on paper it's still kind of dumb the
reason I do think it gets pulled off is
the performance Michelle Gomez who plays
Missy really is able to grab the parts
of John Sims performance that worked
well but even sort of reaching back to
the classic very arched kind of master
that we got with people like Roger
Delgado who originated the role she just
works really well and she does feel
properly like the master it is a new
tank besides beyond these physical
transformation she kind of embraced the
femininity of the character but that
femininity in a way kind of took the
edge off a bit of the fill and buoyance
that John Sims had with his first
appearance at the very least where it
didn't work for me so much but she's
sort of adapted that slightly into this
sort of feminized flamboyance which I
think works better it's kind of funny
that way cuz I mean we've had a number
of jokes over the course of the show
both from France and even in Canon
poking fun at the relationship between
the doctor and the master and hinting
that there's some sort of actual
attraction between the master and the
doctor that became a little bit more
blatant here but now that we know that
Time Lords can swap genders does the
notion of gay or straight even mean
anything anymore no no I don't think so
but it now suddenly made that odd
undercurrent which I think felt most
prevalent back when Anthony Ainley was
playing the role but that now is sort of
twisted by it being a aspect of
femininity and it just kind of works
better again sort of on paper the idea
of gender swapping the master into a
woman
I don't like that idea in concept but
the execution is very good which I said
that a couple of times over the course
of the series there's a number of
episodes and a number of things that
they did that on paper I'm like that's
not gonna work but there really were no
total fall down episodes of this entire
series the weakest one was in the
forests of the night but even that one
was decent it wasn't bad but a lot of
these episodes just had ideas that I did
that if you had told me the pitch of the
episode I would have been what really
I'm talking about episodes like into the
Dalek robot of Sherwood kill the moon
these are weird silly goofy in some
cases outright dumb ideas but they make
it work to slightly varying degrees but
I mean again nothing completely fell
down and Missy very much fits that mold
it's an idea I don't like in concept but
they sold me on it I'm on board and most
of the questions I would have had about
the master coming back which we all knew
was inevitable anyway we're addressed
and they were dressed in the way that I
like we didn't sit down have a long
conversation about exactly what he did
to come back but we just established the
few keys that I needed to have
established yes
Gallifrey was saved and every aspect of
Gallifrey was saved which does mean that
Rassilon and the council who were trying
to initiate that whole thing of ripping
apart time and turning the time loads
into beings of consciousness only they
were still alive as well now we may or
may not ever see them again but
theoretically they could come back so
that kind of just the fact that we were
seeing Missy across multiple points in
time got addressed and again just with
little toss off lines there were just
little plugs for what could have been
holes and now they aren't holes Moffat
is quite good at that I find and I also
like how blatant the master is just
insanity is brought up at a couple of
points just to make the point that if
this plan or his goal his purse hey I
gotta get used to saying that now if her
goals don't make total sense part of the
reason - that may just be she's crazy
and I know for some people that may seem
like a cop-out but honestly you go back
and some of his schemes even back into
the classic era that's the only thing I
can come up with that makes sense some
of the time sometimes it comes up with
really good really meticulously plans
schemes other times you
stuff like wait why would you ever think
that's a good idea that that would work
or what I see what you're doing but
what's the endgame of that what are you
possibly gonna end up with well maybe he
doesn't always know maybe he's flying by
the seat of his pants maybe he's just
nuts and Missy yeah she's just kind of
nuts
she's together enough to be very very
very dangerous but a little bit gone too
we did get the wrap-up and conclusion on
Clara that I really was desperate for I
I said it repeatedly across this series
I I am done with Clara
now she was much better in this series
than she ever was at any point we saw
her previously and I was happy to have
her along but I'm glad they closed out a
story and they ended it Danny pink
really did help develop her as a
character and he himself was really good
and he played very well and he was paid
off very well to that said I've got
Nicola logistical questions particularly
in regards to how the fact that he died
factors into what we saw and listened
with what was very clearly his
descendant and I maybe I need to rewatch
listen but I don't see how we can
reconcile him being dead with what we
see with that descendent of Danny from
the crazy far future and the connection
that he's got with Clara I need to
re-watch it to see if I can reconcile
that but right now it feels like a whole
just about the only hole I can find to
be fair but it's bugging me slightly so
he brought up Danny what happened to
Danny which brings us to Cybermen a
pretty nifty idea the idea that they
they could now convert the dead it's an
interesting twist and when I did my
spoiler free talking about dark water
that was the reveal that I'd forgotten
because we've seen the Cybermen in
promotional material so I should've
remembered that they were coming
whatever reason he completed up my head
and I'm so glad that it did because that
moment cuz you've you've been seeing the
design that sort of circled with the
smaller circle for however long the
episodes been going on and you've only
been seeing one of it but then those
doors closed it's on both sides of the
door and the Cyberman music cue kicks in
that that was a wonderful moment I was
so glad I'd forgot
they were gonna be in this episode
because when I saw that oh that was good
and it was a pretty good use of the
Cybermen as well but the main issue with
the Cybermen always seems to be one of
motivation they weren't pretty well as
villains and his monsters and everything
else but you know you're just so OneNote
in terms of what they're trying to do
just convert everyone convert everyone
convert everyone not for a purpose not
for a goal it's just kind of what they
do at this point I suppose in some ways
that's an overcorrection to classic era
Cybermen who tended to be a little bit
more scheming a bit especially in their
later appearances but it just it didn't
work but I sort of liking this that
we're not really dealing with pure
Cybermen they're not part of the Siberia
tour whatever we're calling sort of the
collective of the Cybermen they're under
the control of Missy which allows them
to function slightly differently not
just in terms of raising the dead which
is again a very cool idea but also just
in terms of it makes them a little bit
less predictable I do have one thing and
then this this is a nitpick I will admit
this but it's bothering me that every
time they update the Cyberman appearance
and they change it however they do that
that just becomes a standard and what we
always use going forward I've got a
problem with sort of the timeline of
this because when we saw this design it
was in the far future dealing with this
heavily upgraded version of the Cybermen
who were crazy fast and like just one of
them on a planet you got to blow up the
whole planet because they can take out
everything well this version of Cybermen
that we get they look like those
Cybermen that we saw in nightmare and
silver but they don't seem to have all
the capabilities that those Cybermen
have I mean they've got some new ones
they've got the flight and everything
and that's fine that's cool and we don't
have to worry about that getting carried
over because like I said before these
seem to be sort of isolated Cybermen but
I kind of wish that we could have more
distinct appearing Cybermen for whatever
part of their actual timeline things
fall into because everything this goes
back to the old show to every time they
update the look that just became the
Cybermen and yes it's consistent with
the idea that they're constantly
upgrading but we're not always seeing
them in chronological order they are
chronological order I don't know maybe
I'm overanalyzing that too much but it's
it's
it's a nitpick it bugs me a little bit
last episode also had some really good
use of recurring characters because we
have the return of Kate Stewart who I
loved before we also had good who I was
really really sorry to see get killed I
didn't like it when it happened but I
also even liked just within about 10
seconds after it happened I was calling
no but it's sunk in why it had to happen
the master had to kill her because Missy
was a lot of fun and you can't just have
the master be too much fun because then
you run the risk of the master kind of
becoming like Loki in the Marvel movies
where he's so much fun
you can't ever just get rid of him you
can't kill him off now I'll sort of get
to the killing off of the master in a
second I'll come back to that but my
point is they sort of become a weird
sort of middle not quite here or not
quite villain thing if they're too much
fun
am I having Missy kill Osgood who was a
very likable character wanted to just
see her show up again especially with
the boat I just instantly made me smile
and I've always liked her that
immediately just rings the bell of this
woman is dangerous it had to make it
clear just because the master swap
genders does not mean that Missy is a
watered down or less dangerous version
so I absolutely understand the reason
why I was good had to get killed I was
still sorry to see it happen though as
for Kate when I thought they killed her
because I actually honestly did when she
got sucked out of that plane and because
I figured if the doctor doesn't doesn't
like materialize the TARDIS around her
in mid fall or something then she's dead
and I really thought they killed her
that one really bothered me but then
when we get to the end and she's not
dead and the reason what this I heard up
I did I got I got the lump of my throat
just a nod to it being her father and
then also this classic character who was
just Oh awesome character I mean he he
had gotten a really nice sort of post
death send-off in series 6 but now just
this extra nugget it was it was
beautiful it really was it was touching
and it was beautiful and it was perfect
but since I bring up that one straggling
Cyberman they also have to bring up that
it appeared to kill Missy now I'm
calling it right now that
not what happened couple reasons well
actually only one reason it's the
appearance of the disintegration blasted
with a Cyberman gun Cybermen guns have
never disintegrated we've never see that
be the case now granted we did not see
these particular version of the Cybermen
shoot anyone else that I can think of in
that episode so I suppose it's possible
that the guns did have this if but we've
never ever in this series has have
Cybermen been the disintegrating types
it just doesn't fit their MO because
they want the body especially these
virgins in the Cybermen if they can
convert the dead why would they
disintegrate that leaves them with
nothing to work with so initial thought
is just she used the shot from that side
of it as cover to teleport I mean that's
my call for how it's gonna be I didn't
she's not dead she can't be dead I am
also really glad that they didn't have
the doctor find out where Gallifrey was
and I like that they're gonna tease that
out for a while because I got really
worried when the master gave coordinates
and then the doctor said he went there
and found it obviously you know that we
then got the flash and found out that he
was lying to clara about it but
initially i was like oh no this soon
because this has happened a couple times
in the show the the most recent time was
when the Daleks had their memory of the
doctor wiped and then like a year later
they know who he is completely and it's
back to things as they were I understand
the status quo will get re-established
eventually but I just I want to see the
journey take longer and in the case of
this I I've got very mixed feelings
about him ever finding Gallifrey again
so I kind of liked the ongoing chase and
that is now a quest for I do kind of
hope that a next series at least that
it's not like his overriding mission I
kind of hope that Missy misdirecting the
doctor and just the pain that you saw
from him that he didn't find Gallifrey
so it took the wind out of his sails for
a little bit and he's not gonna be
actively pursuing Gallifrey all through
next series I want to see him sort of
bounce around a little bit I was he
bounced around untethered even though as
I said Clara worked much better this
series than she has before I didn't like
that the doctor kept getting tethered
back to earth and her all the time I
want to see him just go out there
and travel and just do that with
whoever's new companion is which I am
really ready for either a male companion
or someone who's not human or someone
who's at least not from earth and not
from the current time era just please
shake it up I'm done with young
attractive girls from the modern era I'm
just I'm done but it was maybe the one
criticism that I would level to this
series as a whole which was that it did
in hindsight feel rather tethered to
earth and tethered to Clara now I kind
of like the dynamic that she's not
travelling with him all the time and
he's just going off doing his own thing
and just coming back for her
occasionally I like that concept and I
like that dynamic but because we're not
spending time with him while he's off
doing his own thing and we're only
touching base when he's coming back and
getting her it does sort of feel a
little bit like she's yanking on his
leash a little bit which is exactly what
Missy said so I suppose the fact that it
worked that way plays into how things
worked out quite well and it all makes
sense but it's still to my personal
preference the about the one overall
thing to the series that I'm like yeah
but really this this was a stellar
series it was so well written him so
well constructed Peter Capaldi was great
Clara was as good as she ever got there
wasn't a single episode that I would
call a throwaway I'm just really pumped
and really stoked to see what comes in
the future and I just hoped that Capaldi
feels a bit more front and center and
again dealing with the overall
especially what happens in the finale I
get you know him being tethered to Clara
and her sort of almost sharing equal
billing because when she has her thing
at the start of this last episode where
she says I'm the doctor now anyone who's
paying attention should know in the
audience well no she's not but the fact
that she has the confidence to say that
it's not just a bluff she has been
filling his shoes a couple of times in a
number of episodes in this series so it
all built and played out very well so
she kind of needed to have that sort of
equal billing with him I'm kind of ready
for her companion who's just gonna hang
back and ask the occasional question
occasionally asked just the right
question to kick off the doctor's idea
but who isn't gonna try and wrestle
control from him the way I felt
did sometimes I mean I'm not saying I
want a spineless companion but I did I I
want the doctor to be more than 50% of
the show I want him at least 60 70 is my
preference but this series he felt about
50% of the of the series which again not
really a complete but an observation and
not what I want to become the norm going
forward so I think this wraps it up
we'll be back in December because Nick
Frost playing Santa Claus and I'm really
excited to see how that's gonna play out
you know there was a part of me that
would have been really skeptical about
the idea of Santa Claus just turning up
but given that this whole series was
littered with stuff like that
I would have thought that's a lousy idea
but they pulled it off and in some cases
brilliantly I'm all born I want to see
what happens so I guess that about wraps
this up I do have some additional
thoughts and all sort of the
implications of what Missy is and what
happened there but I think that's gonna
be a separate video after I've sort of
had a little more time to digest all of
this but I'm gonna be coming back to
that you'll see but what about you how
did Missy work for you did you buy it
did you enjoy it was it fun did you
think it was the worst idea of the show
has ever had whatever it is you think
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned